AI just went nuclear it's gone from a
niche subject to basically all anyone
can talk about artificial artificial
artificial intelligence is making rapid
strides there's talk of a new Evolution
that could fundamentally change life on
our planet today people are reacting to
AI the same way they did to the
development of the atomic bombs 75 years
ago and that reaction is putting the
future of AI in Jeopardy because there's
a wave of Regulation coming that could
prevent AI from reaching its incredible
full potential yeah the nuclear
Regulatory Commission that governs how
you build a plant and is licensed do you
agree Mr Alderman that these tools
you're creating should be licensed these
two technologies nuclear and AI have
more in common than you think AI has
been making tons of headlines but
they've mostly been about Microsoft and
Google fighting it out to integrate AI
into their search engines now don't get
me wrong the battle between big Tech is
important but the bigger story is what's
happening on a global scale governments
are fighting for control over AI systems
and politicians are mapping out plans to
create new regulations we got it wrong
with nuclear but we can still get it
right with AI and by the end of this
video you'll know exactly how
the technology is the change the world
create massive questions should they be
used at all if so how and who gets to
access them this was true for nuclear
Innovations decades ago and it's true
today for artificial intelligence both
of these Technologies actually have two
entirely separate use cases government
and civilian you can visualize them both
on an X and Y graph so let's do it first
let's look at nuclear prior to the
creation of the atomic bomb no one had
access to nuclear technology but after
World War II it became clear that
nuclear had applications Beyond just
weapons that Clarity created a common
vision of a nuclear-powered future with
abundant energy too cheap to measure in
that moment of hopefulness the world
shifted to the top right quadrant of the
graph nuclear weapons were proliferating
but so was the promise of nuclear power
because of this early progress people
started to dream even bigger perhaps
instead of a world with nuclear power
and nuclear weapons we could just have
the former what if all those talented
nuclear scientists left the defense
sector and focused on improving civilian
nuclear technology that brings us to the
bottom right quadrant a world with lots
of nuclear power but no nuclear weapons
sounds like an incredible outcome but of
course that's not how it panned out
the cold war led to an aggressive arms
race between the United States and the
Soviet Union and the world entered a
multi-decade era defined by fear of
nuclear Annihilation and even though we
managed to avoid complete Annihilation
the number of nuclear weapons
skyrocketed while nuclear power
stagnated slowly as militaries continued
to develop nuclear weapons and civilian
developments slowed to a crawl we
shifted from the top right quadrant to
the top left this is the worst of all
possible outcomes now maybe endless
nuclear power in a world free of nuclear
weapons was always a pipe dream but we
did have a real shot at using the window
of time where the world's most powerful
nations were stockpiling nuclear weapons
to also invest in nuclear power but we
didn't and very soon I'll explain why
that's relevant for AI but first let's
quickly recap how this happened how did
Humanity discover what's basically an
infinite energy glitch and then instead
of scaling it up to provide endless
power we locked it away inside nuclear
submarines and aircraft carriers today
nuclear power generates about 10 10
percent of global electricity it should
be so much more but nuclear power keeps
running into hurdles the biggest one is
that nuclear power plant construction
costs have dramatically increased over
the last few decades in the 1980s the
state of Washington had to cancel a
project to build several nuclear power
plants after costs skyrocketed from 4
billion to over 24 billion in just a few
years and more recently two reactors in
South Carolina were scrapped after costs
more than doubled from 10 billion to 25
billion you'd think the team in South
Carolina would have learned from the
disaster in Washington decades earlier
but they didn't so how do the people
behind these projects mess up so badly
and why does it keep happening
proven Technologies normally get cheaper
over time we've seen this in
semiconductor manufacturing where the
learning curve has allowed prices to
plummet and cheap electronics to make
their way into every household cars flat
screen TVs air travel they've all become
much more affordable over time not
nuclear power plants though in the late
1960s nuclear power plants cost around
one thousand dollars per kilowatt of
capacity just 10 years later that cost
nearly 10x to nine thousand dollars the
reason regulation starting in the 1960s
and 70s nuclear power plant operators
have been hit with a huge number of new
regulations and these regulations aren't
static they often change even during the
construction process imagine building a
house out of wood and then halfway
through being told that building with
wood was suddenly against the law that's
what happened to companies building
nuclear power plants just look at this
chart of changes to nuclear regulations
over time in every year except for 1991
something changed and there were dozens
of changes every year during the 1970s
that's why nuclear power isn't more
economically competitive but where did
these regulations come from what
happened at 4 am on March 28 1979 the
unit 2 reactor of the Three Mile Island
Nuclear Generating Station in
Pennsylvania partially melted down the
accident had a huge impact on global
nuclear safety regulations and directly
led to changes in how plants were built
and operators were trained cleaning and
decommissioning the site cost about a
billion dollars sounds pretty serious so
how many people died at Three Mile
Island well zero okay so what about
injuries also zero several studies have
tried to determine if there was a
statistically significant increase in
cancer rates in the part of Pennsylvania
near the reactor and they didn't really
find anything definitive although a
small amount of radioactive gases leaked
into the surrounding environment the
reactors containment structure
successfully prevented the release of
more but here's the interesting thing
remember that chart showing tons of new
regulations on nuclear power plants that
all started right at the beginning of
the 1970s nearly 10 years before Three
Mile Island the accident raised public
concerns about the safety of nuclear
power but people were already worried
about the potential risks and that fear
fueled an industry of consultants and
businesses that sold safety concerns to
governments and safety equipment to
nuclear power plants every time new
regulations rolled out every Power Plant
would have to comply and that meant
millions of dollars spent on new safety
equipment and oversight procedures don't
get me wrong these regulations weren't
all bad nuclear accidents do happen and
they should be prevented places like
Fukushima and Chernobyl are by words for
disaster but it's important to keep
things in perspective nuclear energy is
much safer than almost every other kind
of energy nuclear energy is so safe that
it doesn't even register on this graph
it's safer than wind power maybe that's
because of decades worth of regulations
but there's a point at which regulation
becomes over regulation if you never
leave your house you'll be really safe
but you'll have regrets that's arguably
the situation that we're in with nuclear
power and as I'll explain soon we're
arguably in the same situation today
with AI but humans struggle to stay
rational when thinking about life and
death situations people are more afraid
of flying than driving on the highway
even though planes are way safer than
cars these days the thought of dying in
a plane crash feels completely out of
our control but everyone thinks they can
avoid a car crash if they're a good
driver the same goes for the relative
risks of energy production wind power is
really only dangerous to the workers who
have to climb to the tops of those
massive windmills that's dangerous work
but it feels within the control of a
single person nuclear radiation is
invisible and that's scary but it really
shouldn't be because although it's
serious business nuclear radiation just
isn't actually that dangerous here's an
interesting fact how many nuclear bombs
do you think have gone off in the past
100 years most people know about the two
used during the second world war clever
people might think of a few test bombs
that were dropped as well so what maybe
like 10 but the answer isn't 10. it's
over 2 500. nuclear bombs have been
detonated all over the world just take a
look at this map and yet we've learned
to harness this technology and avoid
doom and this relates perfectly to the
current moment in artificial
intelligence development just like
nuclear we have an incredibly powerful
new technology on our hands AI could
change the economy and the global
balance of power at the same time it's
hard to clearly Define its impact and
most people don't understand the
technical side of AI this uncertainty
causes fear and as we know fear leads to
regulations we've seen it in the last
few weeks at the recent G7 Summit in
Japan world leaders talked a lot about
generative AI the outcome of those talks
was the Hiroshima process as part of
this process the governments of the G7
countries that's the US UK Germany
France Canada Italy and Japan agreed
that they would each hold cabinet level
discussions and present results back to
the G7 by the end of 2023. the leaders
cited a concern that AI could lead to a
new wave of incredibly convincing deep
fakes and disinformation that could put
further stress on Democratic systems the
European Union is already taking steps
towards regulating AI such as requiring
companies to notify users when they're
interacting with AI and banning the
real-time identification of people in
public the Hiroshima process sounds
reasonable governments should be looking
into AI but the risk is that regulations
are driven by fear and lack of
understanding that would bring us back
to the upper left quadrant of our Matrix
a world with plentiful AI Weaponry in
the hands of superpowers in Rogue States
while regular people don't get any of
the benefits we can avoid this outcome
but we need to understand what's
actually going on let's start with the
risks in the recent Senate subcommittee
hearing on AI regulation the Democratic
senator from Connecticut Richard
Blumenthal opened with a fake AI
generated voice recording designed to
sound like him
too often
we have seen what happens when
technology outpaces regulation the
unbridled exploitation of personal data
the proliferation of disinformation and
the deepening of societal inequalities
that voice was not mine the words were
not mine and the audio was an AI voice
cloning software deep fakes are getting
pretty good the amount of AI generated
content is already exploding and it's
not going to slow down anytime soon open
source models like stable diffusion make
it simple for anyone with a graphics
card to produce remarkable images but
the cat's out of the bag at this point
the only way to actually stop the
creation of fake images would involve
seriously infringing on people's civil
liberties there's a weird misconception
probably from the 2016 election that
political misinformation is new in fact
it's literally thousands of years old in
the 13th century BC the Egyptian Pharaoh
Ramses the Great was fighting a battle
against the Hittites neither side could
gain any ground and the fight ended in a
stalemate the Egyptians and Hittites
signed a treaty ending the battle but
Ramses didn't feel like taking the L so
he launched a propaganda campaign to
make it look like the battle was a
stunning victory for the Egyptians he
had murals painted on the walls of every
Temple showing himself smiting foes to
make it look like a decisive Victory or
consider this photo of Stalin strolling
along a canal in Moscow here's the
original Soviet censors doctored the
photo after Stalin had the man on the
right Nikolai yezov executed today we're
still dealing with political
misinformation and the only solution
remains developing a strong
understanding of what can be fabricated
Sam Altman the founder of openai the
company that built Chachi PT outlined
exactly how people will adjust to these
new creative tools during the Senate
hearing when Photoshop came onto the
scene a long time ago you know for a
while people were really quite fooled by
photoshopped images and then pretty
quickly developed an understanding that
images might be photoshopped fortunately
this is already happening most young
people are extremely skeptical about
anything they see or read online instead
of needing to shut down AI content
generation we can instead develop
relationships with trusted resources
that we know are authentic
disinformation isn't a big enough
problem for us to justify stopping
further development into AI but what
about AI putting people out of their
jobs
even if you're not worried about getting
tricked by a political misinformation
campaign the idea of AI taking
everyone's job is the scary one but I
don't think it should be fear about
technology replacing human labor is
nothing new for hundreds of years people
have argued that industrial progress
will cause broad unemployment you've
probably heard the term Luddite to
describe someone who's anti-progress but
have you ever thought about where the
word comes from during the Industrial
Revolution the luddites were English
textile workers who opposed the use of
cost-saving Machinery including new
types of looms they would often launch
clandestine raids to destroy these
machines but the thing is they were
wrong there has been a nearly continual
rise in both jobs and wages in
capitalist countries since the
Industrial Revolution but despite
Decades of steady job growth there have
still been two major anti-technology
moral panics during the 2000s everyone
was worried that the internet would
cause significant job losses due to
Outsourcing and then in the 2010s that
fee shifted to robots stealing physical
jobs
so far both of those fears have
basically been unfounded and now we're
hearing the same Rumblings when it comes
to AI so many people are saying this
time is different whenever you hear that
phrase you should always be a little
skeptical there are a bunch of reasons
why AI won't cause mass unemployment let
me explain first off despite all the
crazy headlines AI isn't actually
developing all that quickly sure it
feels like chat GPT came out of nowhere
and changed everything overnight but it
didn't open ai's GPT model was first
released five years ago and the company
is nearly 10 years old at this point and
the history of AI goes back decades with
a long series of incredible
breakthroughs followed by long Winters
where progress stagnated now that's not
to say that we're not at an inflection
point we absolutely are just like the
iPhone revolutionized the mobile phone
industry and made smartphones a thing AI
is at a point where it will switch from
Niche uses to being broadly available
everywhere you look but that doesn't
necessarily mean job losses aside from
chat gbt the most successful AI product
to date is arguably github's co-pilot
which uses the same GPT model to provide
code suggestions while programming
copilot has been out for two years now
and is basically universally loved by
software developers it doesn't matter if
you're brand new to programming or one
of the best programmers in the world
copilot improves productivity hands down
but no one is replacing programmers with
copilot it just doesn't work like that
the clue is in the name AI models like
copilot currently work best when they're
used alongside a human pilot the AI is
just the co-pilot helping to do
repetitive tasks and avoid obvious
errors every commercial passenger plane
has at least two pilots and they're both
essential but what about less complex
tasks there are lots of people who do
basic data entry for a living or simple
translation and AI models are
essentially superhuman at these tasks
now it's true that some of these jobs
will be replaced but the thing about
capitalism is that it's the best
mechanism ever invented for creating new
types of jobs already lots of people who
did Manual data entry are helping train
AI models to do new tasks they've
shifted over and that Trend will
continue for quite some time and there
are other areas of the economy that feel
ripe for disruption but might be more
resistant than you think just look at
this chart that shows the various prices
of goods and services over time what
you'll notice is that Healthcare and
education have gotten dramatically more
expensive while technology like TVs and
software have dropped in price
significantly technology has never been
evenly applied to our economy certain
sectors benefit significantly from
advances in technology while in others
we're basically still doing things the
same way as we did them decades ago
sometimes Industries lag behind because
we just haven't found a way to use
technology effectively there no one
thinks chat GPT is going to put
construction workers out of a job for
instance but sometimes there are other
structural factors at Play Take lawyers
for instance as far back as 1973 the
American Bar Association was worried
about the effect that autumn Nation
would have on the legal profession they
established a special committee and went
to work studying how lawyers would use
computers in the future their conclusion
was Dire they predicted that automation
would dramatically reduce the number of
lawyers as well as how much money
lawyers got paid but over the following
50 years the exact opposite happened
today there are more lawyers than ever
and they're making more money than ever
before I think a few different things
might happen to the legal profession
over the next few years first they might
just ban the use of AI outright the bar
association already determines who can
legally practice law so they have the
authority to do that but they could also
learn to work with AI effectively and
add value in other ways just as they did
during the first Computing Revolution
even if AI does wind up having a
significant impact on the legal
profession my bet is on it happening
very slowly after all courtroom sketch
artists are still working today even
more than a hundred years after the
invention of the camera I'd be very
surprised if mid-journey puts them out
of business we've talked about
disinformation and unemployment but what
about the ultimate bad outcome what if
AI becomes super intelligent and decides
to eliminate all humans Terminator style
even though it sounds like pure Science
Fiction it's not completely unimaginable
AI Safety Research has been a serious
field of study for more than 10 years at
this point if artificial intelligence
becomes dramatically smarter than every
human being how would Humanity keep it
in check well fortunately even the most
hardcore AI pessimists don't think this
is happening anytime soon the stat
you'll hear quoted most often is that 50
percent of AI researchers think that AI
could produce an extremely bad outcome
for Humanity that sounds scary a 50
chance of an extremely bad outcome but
when you dig into the data the numbers
tell a different story see that stat
includes anyone who assigned more than a
10 chance of a bad outcome so even for
the researchers who do believe AI
possesses a real existential threat they
generally think that there is a very low
probability that a bad outcome will
happen the important thing to remember
is that no one wants an AI takeover
every AI research organization takes
this stuff extremely seriously that's
why Sam Altman is testifying in front of
Congress about it Sam has clearly
thought deeply about the impact of
artificial intelligence and that's why
he's asking for regulation much earlier
than most other Tech Founders would but
I think that's a case for optimism
remember the scenario we really want to
avoid is the top left quadrant of our
Matrix
that's the place where civilians and
companies don't have access to AI but
governments can do almost anything they
want
nuclear weapons have dramatically
shifted the global balance of power many
world leaders want AI weapons to do
exactly the same thing in their favor
China already uses AI to conduct
surveillance on their population new
developments will only make
authoritarian control easier to
implement that's the concern with
something like the Hiroshima process
that the leaders of the G7 countries
want to implement carefully weighing
risks and benefits is good but waiting
for too long when countries like China
Russia and Iran are already exploring
the potential military uses of AI That's
a real risk there is a potential for a
good outcome here though one where no
one is fooled by Deep fakes where no one
loses their job where everyone gets an
AI copilot to make them more effective
and creative that's the world we want to
fight for so getting regulation right
here will be critical if the government
goes too far it will restrict Innovation
and that's why Sam isn't advocating for
totally locking down AI development AI
is only going to become a bigger topic
of conversation over the next few years
we have an opportunity need to avoid
making the same mistakes we did with
nuclear power it won't be easy but if we
succeed we'll be safer richer and
happier as a result but if we fail we'll
get stuck in the top left part of that
Matrix now in order to understand the
full history of AI you have to watch
this video next thanks a lot